in a wind welcome to this video playing
Karen 84 I got a really good run at the
moment I have like you know 17 out of 18
or so in the last games it's really nice
that okay I was a favorite most of the
time or pretty much all of the time it
still has a really huge school
we'll probably transpose to a king's
inion but black I know okay was c5 is
going to do it yet the Benoni is
certainly good even though keeping the
tension make sense as well so let's just
go into the Benoni here one reason why I
like that I mean it is generally a good
structure who white any habit the 97
moves is a bit early not quite clear
okay how is going to free his position
yeah so is six
I can take play e5 a completely ruinous
pawn structure for pawn but I'm a little
bit uncertain if this is really the the
best way to play you know Bishop f4 so
it's not bad
we'll probably go E 5 then no need to do
any Mouse acrobatic sim
hmm hey I'm not sure about all this
maybe he's fine
Whoopie 8 it's not exactly a move that I
expected so try want to try to play a 5
you would assume and we place g5 it's
really hard okay but do this I should be
able to block him on the light squares
entirely the 91 has c2 III as a good as
a good route good road to improvement
he gets age - ah
he gets age five and that is not great I
mean it's not terrible if he does but
it's nothing that I wanted to allow some
other didn't didn't occur to me okay
nine three three it has to go there
anyway so let's do it
and age five is a move I could not
really prevent yeah I don't know what
what what took him what took him so long
yeah I can't play 93 here's some it's a
possibility but him taking us certainly
easier g-form maybe even maybe reform
I don't understand why this works what G
for here buddy
what's going on
[Music]
hmm yeah what what on earth did you look
okay probably I should probably go him
and prevent any efore efore business
he's got to check on age three but that
is the only activity or activity is the
only thing that is annoying queen h3
however is I mean are threatening I'm
covering g2 but I should have seen that
a little bit should have seen that
earlier it's a bit of a pain
opening up the second-ranked so that I
can play move like rook F to Queen d2 to
cover G to stopping up the air form
I don't like how I play this somehow it
feels shake him night age 3:00 a.m. and
9:00 a phone now the thing is I don't
love to take I probably have to but
maybe it's not so bad
now that I see the theater if he takes
with the upon I have Knight to c4 which
is in fact that looks fairly very good
maybe G form
it's first pushing away to g6 and now
yes that has SG form that has g4 under
under on the agenda let's prevent that
simply I cannot stand the idea that he
got the g4
and that looks still fairly safe
a g3 Scott also
what a pain
what is he killing himself the rook was
hanging didn't my look hang on edge for
it was really old yeah it was a very
straightforward I mean yeah I was
winning for a long time but then I
gradually has screwed it out if we if we
join him this looks like fine but not
nothing special probably they played
loopy aid and then g5 and that is pretty
awful okay maybe you can argue about my
move order but don't blame it actually
likes what I'm doing here
no Knights a tool not this one yeah the
problem is simply with the h5 move which
I did not take into account that much
you should play it right away
and here white should be better but it's
nothing special
this I would have gone to here I guess
no this is given by the end every time I
should be better here so and I'd see to
me and then taking them on yeah I mean
even that is better for what for what's
the deal why do that damn sorry I don't
I don't believe that I don't believe it
at all
that cannot be better for lucky that's
simply not possible but the two nights
here just just just not well positioned
and the bishop on g7 is eternally dead I
don't think that like Amy better okay
it's close to equal ish now okay will be
eight nights and to age five now I also
can play 93 which looks fine because
this is certainly good for white at the
end it's always just totally dead Bishop
and I have f5 this is a full square
weakness that can never be covered by
upon while after Bishop regrouping I can
play g3 and prevent him from using those
squares anyway we had this capture I go
back at 5:05 I mean I don't know just
bluntness is peace then now I should
defend this better 94 I think it should
be okay and this is actually this is
just a repetition or what it what did I
do that that's terrible I should start
with this it seems I mean you can just
count it I'm a piece off for not much
well it was extremely stupid I can just
draw here like that that would have been
embarrassing Wow and now things are back
in order
I'm still thinking they're in this area
of like everything wins but yeah I
should go to g4 here maybe
the thing is like here I have this which
I did not see now that's a nice tactical
point but ninety-fourth of course not so
nice for it's not spawning anything only
only here I think here this is
completely winning and then I made it
interesting somehow yeah g4i no no no
let's panic be a bit of a panic mode and
this doesn't work I thought that was a
clever move but it isn't I can just take
yeah ok of course he captures but after
this there is no movement
yeah
you know just just take aged form and
yf2 nh4 I can't take everything you had
a complete meltdown here make no sense
at all and you have time I mean two
seconds increment is plenty so bit of a
v8 via the game at the end okay guys
thanks a lot for watching